[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right glad to have our next guest
there's only a handful of guests so we
can do long-form interviews with a
little bit handful of guests with whom
we can do long-form interviews and it'd
still be interesting yeah we don't hit
our lives bye-bye yes 3dr yeah we dr.
Peterson and now you said our three he's
panicky no we're not gonna do three
hours and of course we think more than
anyone this next gentleman is Dennis
Prager you can follow him on the Twitter
at Dennis Prager I believe yeah at
Dennis Prager sometimes there's an
underscore in there and Prager you the
real thing a guy does unbelievable mr.
Bricker thank you being back sir
you know what I loved about what you did
is very impressive you corrected
yourself to be even more precise there
are very few people we could do a long
interview with no no that's not true a
long interview with and still be
interesting I love that I do the same
thing but it shows you are monitoring
yourself for accuracy and that's very
impressive
thank you I also tried to correct my
grammar because I realized that I just I
just spoke out of turn it was just a
disaster to start and so I try to
correct it you know it's funny I right
away I have abandon any of my notes I
was going to ask you and this is the way
it goes I always talk when I tell people
to go hey you know you seem comfortable
speaking in front of an audience any
tips and I always say you'll never be
thought a fool if you speak simply and
effectively you see so many people
misuse words or try to use you from you
try to use sort of colloquialisms they
don't even understand it so if you don't
just stay away from it and no one's
gonna call you on it's like Joey
Tribbiani with a thesaurus yes exactly
have you did you learn that at an early
age I knew what a barrier I started
speaking at 21 and I and I oddly in a
very odd life I was sent to the Soviet
Union to learn things and I came back to
America
and and they said all young man who
speaks Russian just got back from the
Soviet Union so I had a lot of speeches
at a very very early age but I knew
immediately that the more I spoke real
that's my favorite word by the way
real real the more I spoke real the more
people listened and when I hear talk
show hosts often who or just starting
out or in even just mid-career and they
have a different way of speaking on the
radio than in real life and I tuned out
it's not interesting to me well and
therefore now this is Dennis Prager ITSO
talking Ceridian but nobody nobody talks
like that yes that's why people say when
they meet me Wow you're just the same as
on the radio and that's the greatest
compliment I can get they are right it's
the exact same guy that's true you're
you're taller than I expected I remember
when I first met you that's a shock to
people yeah you know I think it is a
shock to people looking at me now I'm
six foot four but looking at me now I
could be four foot three it's true
we have no idea you know what it is I
think it's because you're proportional
and I've talked a lot of you'll think
wow you're a lot taller than I expected
you know people like if you think of
Sean Hannity or a lot of these you know
these newscasters or Anderson Cooper
they have these big square head it's
Josh Brolin yeah they have heads like
refrigerators and then they're tiny guys
are not big guys whereas you have a head
like a normal person I'm not saying you
have a shrunken head you have a normal
head and so in comparison to short guys
with a big head the camera it's a it's a
total facade people don't realize it's
not an accurate representation of who
you are yeah yeah well you have to worry
about it because you do a lot of radio
but still you know you got your hair and
it's it's going well for you um let me
let me let me ask you this it's funny
you just said real I was just watching
this filmed all eyes on me with Tupac
and that's a I this is true and I'm
watching it and they gloss over his ten
arrests and they gloss over you know
that he just so happy well he just so
happened to be in the room where a rape
occurred with his manager and I glossed
over he just so happened I was be wrong
place wrong time when he shot people who
happened to be undercover cops but it
was always you know keep it real and he
talked about how much he loved his mom
and keep it real respect our women but
all
he did was disrespect women it's become
this cloak keep it real when people
couldn't be keeping it more fake I
wonder if that's the appeal with you I'm
not saying your your you know an
old-timer but you're older than me but
you have a very young audience
I think it's authenticity not all that's
a very interesting subject you raised in
general because I have this odd life of
having done the same thing at 21 that
I'm doing today which is publicly
speaking I can tell you a fascinating
thing that I never would have predicted
when I go to colleges which I do
regularly to speak uh I obviously know
my audience as you know your audience a
good speaker knows their audience young
people take me more seriously the older
I get when with all of the stuff about
the you know society is youth mania and
youth worship the fascinating truth is
but Bernie Sanders was an example yeah
the fascinating truth is that a lot of
people get more credibility with young
people as they get older
well you I think I think some of that is
because I think we're finding ourselves
more and more amidst generations who
don't have those father-son
father/daughter talks I think that's I
think it all to you because there's like
there's a hunger in a in a market for
people who dennis prager shaped hole in
their hearts yeah yeah exactly to speak
so my wisdom I need people's lives you
know
seriously it's I get I get a lot of
attacks and I get a lot of compliments
and one of the compliments that really
does mean a lot to me is especially when
a guy calls up and says you're like a
father figure to me and I always say I'm
happy for you and I'm happy for me
because we guy needs a father figure
either in his own father or in addition
to his own father
yeah sure and every every woman needs a
father figure unless you want to install
a stripper pole in the trailer park that
is very very some prices pretty right
well let me ask you this because this
transitions to what we were about to
talk about Prager University
but this teaches a lot of
and I will say by the way the age thing
is true of always said it's not about
age it's about relevancy and I don't
necessarily even think it's because
you're older I think it's that you
maintain relevancy and I think you're
become more and more relevant in this
age of identity politics and populism
some form of consistency that people can
use as a reference point when I was on
Fox News and I was the youngest
contributor I made sure I said don't
ever use my age because I never wanted
to be the young guy who came out just
either my ideas are good or they're not
and I think yours are good and it's
about relevancy do you think that's why
I know you guys have a lawsuit maybe
clarify for people who don't know from
prag are you with YouTube these videos
are so family-friendly they're so benign
I guess as far as the hate speech
guidelines but almost all of them are
restricted do you think some of that
targeting is because you're relevant
because you reach people there's no
other possible explanation for those of
your viewers who don't know I'll be very
brief we put out five-minute videos
every week we have about 300 out there
the people who present these videos are
some of the finest minds in the world
whether MIT Stanford Harvard the you
know the usual gang for Pulitzer Prize
winners you will well anything you're no
no you're a fine mind I mean we wouldn't
have had you what for any other reason
you you have your perfect example you
have something relevant to say well I
pre and we appreciate that in any event
you know we put out stuff like you know
Victor Davis Hanson who was his
mild-mannered a human as I have ever met
five minutes on the Korean War
why is that on the restricted list I'll
tell you why because it paints America
positively right wherever we have a
video that paints America or Israel
positively YouTube has put it on the
restricted list which means that if a
family filters out pornography it can't
get that video libraries by definition
can't get it in schools my definition
can't get it now you've seen our stuff
it is the antithesis
of pornography I mean give me a break
its intellectual pornography one could
make the case
what progress its intellectual put to
pornography will make you that's right
yeah no no I agree with you by
forgetting I on everything i mounted the
drugs but but the intellect should get
you high I agree with you on that and in
any event it's purely political they
they don't want an effective
conservative voice and were very
effective we had six hundred million
views last year and most of them were
under 35 years of age yeah well we
talked about this
forward publishing and pray are you
people we went out to with YouTube in
New York I've talked about this on the
Joe Rogan show and your people and the
the forward publishing daily wire people
were the only other people in that room
who stood up everyone was sitting there
quietly kind of nodding and they gave us
a nice lunch in the cheese spread and
talked about the new guidelines
fantastic hummus it was fantastic hummus
it was world-class Google spared no
expense but then I remember I stood up
and said hold on a second we're all here
because we're losing our ability to make
a living on a platform that you actually
advertise to us you advertise to us your
platform for us to use your platform
exclusively to make our living can we
talk about this and some conservatives
think tanks were oh hush don't rock the
boat they wanted to be there and mingle
play game the Prager University lawsuit
and I said it makes sense we're not
playing around I know you aren't playing
around or you're playing for keeps
rather what is what is the status of
this is it a lawsuit exactly is it a
petition for information I don't want to
misspeak no no it is a lawsuit okay
there's it's a breach of contract they
they claim that they will allow anything
that is not pornographic or the like or
incites violence on on their platform so
they either have to change their
platform and say we are open to all
views left-of-centre not two views right
of center or they have to in fact allow
our videos up I mean so it's really it's
a lawsuit
in in not not only because it's a
lawsuit but it's an attempt to get them
to say the truth and the truth at this
moment is that YouTube owned by Google
is political have they
how have they acknowledged your
complaints and they responded at all
what's what's there just a cura stay had
to respond and the response is fairly
weak cheese oh well we're a private
enterprise we could do what we want sure
all of a sudden that all of a sudden
they're big on private enterprise right
but believe me if a baker doesn't want
to bake a cake for a same-sex wedding
right they're not for private enterprise
no no or when it comes to net neutrality
they're the biggest supporters they want
to force ISPs to to play by rules
unfitted in 2015 and we're doing it for
the little guy well what about the
little guy making a living who disagrees
with you I'm gonna trample him so you
said this is I find interesting I didn't
know this because I assumed all of our
stuff it just gets D monetized or
restricted because they find it
offensive fine you know painting
Mohammed as Bob Ross I get it
I don't agree with it but I understand
it but Frager you videos like you said
there you have some of the best minds
you said anything that's Pro America I
understand Israel because of these sort
of I guess sort of I guess you would say
Jewish secularists in Silicon Valley who
have some sort of fascination with
Palestine I don't know what it is
Houston and feminists but it's a big
movement Alice Tinian feminists they are
very anti-israel I've known that for a
long time but pro-america videos you
notice get dinged oh of course that's
why the Korean War one or or one name
that this is hilarious we have one
called America must lead some left-wing
site also has a video called America bus
lead there's is a hun and ours it's
restricted and so where wherever people
should look at the list they go to
Prager you've got to come they could
read the whole lawsuit they could see
what's on the list of the 40 that are
restricted and again if it's if it shows
America in a favorable light the chances
are it will be restricted when you say
you understand the Israel part not the
America part they're very related
one of my books is called why the Jews
it's it's in third edition with Simon &
Schuster and it's an explanation of
anti-semitism but the interesting thing
is that in the third edition I show that
anti-americanism is a variant of
anti-semitism for the exact same reason
Jews have been hated America is hated
and and it's so they do go hand in hand
I don't know anybody for example who who
loves Israel and doesn't love America or
loves America doesn't love it it's very
rare right they almost always or hates
one but not the other that is true they
almost go hand in hand it's kind of for
example you know Joe Rogan was accused
of being an all right not see it because
he had an American flag behind him to
them that's basically my little be the
flag of the Third Reich they see the
American flag they see you with a flag
pin they see patriotic symbolism the
left assumes you're an enemy and just as
surely if I see someone who's patriotic
I go oh he's probably at the very least
moderate or slightly right of center
yeah that's right well the giveaway was
when when Donald Trump gave his speech
in Warsaw last year and said we need to
protect Western civilization the New
York Times said it was a white
supremacist dog was right yeah there was
a dog whistle
yeah Western civilization Western
civilization right don't tell that to
the black and Asian Americans who've
pulled themselves out of poverty in
record numbers in comparison to any
other civilization in the history of
humanity that is interesting that is by
the way why the Jews from Dennis burger
not to be confused with why it's the
Jews by Mel Gibson totally different
look different direction sorry mr.
Prager I know you're both critically
acclaimed both critically acclaimed for
different reasons you know it's funny
that you mentioned the Winter Olympics
are underway and I've noticed this
certainly a lot of the American athletes
and a lot of these competitors worldwide
when they're interviewed when they win
their medals they talk about their
experience or you know my journey not so
much their country and obviously
competing this pride of country or
certainly not as it used to be you know
that America is the greatest force for
good and if you look back in the 40s and
50s and 60s there was a lot of pride you
were
for your country have you noticed that
stark contrasts between I guess sort of
the the post-event interviews today and
those of your EIN watch them as much as
I should to answer you properly but i
I've noticed it over the course of time
look the left hates nationalism except
for one there's one nationalism on earth
they're in love with Palestinian yeah
but outside of Palestinian nationalism
since Marx remember that communist
manifesto ends proletariat of the world
unite
you have nothing to lose but your chains
they divided the world between worker
and owner not between American and
German and French and English they
wanted to abolish national identity from
Marx to today's Democratic Party that
has been a consistent they have no
interest they have contempt for national
identity
right and that's why they for open
borders yes they don't care if ask a
leftist what if 50 million people came
in tomorrow and American identity were
there by simply diluted they go so what
right American identity is fascist
anyway which is for a couple of ironies
they're Palestine not a nation also the
fact that you as you mention okay here
all the stuff you wanted we have gay
marriage now you the trans people can
you know they can hop on up to any
urinal they want
isn't that a national identity you're
proud was compared to people of enforced
abortions of North Korean internment
camps you're saying that Kim Jong sister
stole the show at the ceremony how about
just relating to the national identity
that you've helped create here modern
progressives it's it's it really is
crazy to me modern America is something
they fought for too they should be happy
with well liberals for fourth the left
has always been opposed it's at your
daily statement of mine on my radio show
that liberalism and leftism have almost
nothing in common
the problem is Lib
don't know it hmm that's that's the
there are a few liberals like Harvard
professor what's his name uh Alan
Dershowitz yeah the harvard law
professor who is a big liberal a big
supporter of Hillary Clinton he said to
me and it's on camera it's coming out in
our movie no safe spaces later this year
and they want to dude with Adam Carolla
right and yeah and he said the left is a
much greater threat to liberalism than
the right yeah yeah I think well here's
one thing though I he can say that all
he wants and I agree with him but at a
certain point people like gerschwitz
they do have to say hold on a second
there is no official representation
whatsoever of my point of view in
today's Democratic Party it doesn't
exactly
it's a left-wing party it is no longer a
liberal party Franklin D Roosevelt the
Liberals hero Franklin D Roosevelt
regularly spoke about the need to defend
not only Western civilization but
Christian civilization if a president
said that today they would be
impeachment a movement for impeachment
yeah no that's an important point to me
by the way also the guy who did the
internment camp we were just talking
about that's left left his folk hero
after year do you guys remember this
this wasn't a guy who was necessarily
soft on foreign policy kind of went a
little too far some people argue in that
direction but you know this is one
difference I see from the right in the
left they talk about how closed-minded
the right is and I talked about this I
think with Ruben in Rogan who's like
they say way and its political tribalism
I go hold on a second the right you can
have someone like Dennis Prager you can
have steven crowder you can have Ben
Shapiro you can have my innopolis you
can have Andrew Clavin you can have
libertarians who want to smoke pot and
talk about Bitcoin but they also want a
limited government there are so many
different kinds of people who just
aren't on the far left including people
who hold office by the way but if you
look at the DNC there is no one on the
Left who strays from it for example if
Donald Trump comes out and says
something that's embarrassing we have no
problem saying I listen okay
I like his reversal Mexico City policy
yeah but this was kind of embarrassing i
I don't see you know for example up mr.
dersh wits endorsing Hillary Clinton you
don't see them come out and say well
this is the only
we have but it really is embarrassing
that we are down to Bernie Sanders and
Hillary Clinton people who don't support
freedom of speech people who don't
support the basic right to to
self-preservation with the Second
Amendment
I really am ashamed that there is no one
in the get Democratic Party they should
be at this point they require a third
party to be represented whereas the
right doesn't there's enough of there's
enough of a spectrum it's a very good
point I I have been in three dialogues
around the country with Dershowitz and
I've asked them exactly that for him now
to acknowledge the moral failure of
liberalism in America I think it would
be too painful so but you know what but
but seriously you know what he's a much
greater value to us continuing to
identify as a liberal then if he were to
say you know what the truth is I'm a
conservative and I don't believe he's a
conservative but it doesn't matter race
value he attacking the left from a
liberal standpoint is what we need more
liberals to do but liberals have been
brainwashed into thinking their enemy is
the right right but their enemy is not
the right their enemy is the left yeah
that's a good point and I guess you know
we're using these terminology like
liberal left right but put it this way
with the Republican Party the right wing
listen I get it the Republican part no
one the Republican Party fully
represents me right people always put
the two-party system man here's a deal I
come from Canada where it's a
parliamentary system that really sucks
because you can have someone who gets
30-something percent of the vote doesn't
represent even close to a plurality of
the nation and all of a sudden they're
running the country so the two-party
system it's like the 10-point must
system and mixed martial arts it's about
as close to something that works as
we've has why I had the primaries
yeah there's way of the primaries but
that's a big difference for all I left
right I would I would not be able to
let's say we just got down to a
candidate who was a Republican or
conservative and say yeah I endorse this
person wholeheartedly if they were
against the second amendment if they
were against freedom of speech if they
were Pro funding abortions overseas I
would have to part ways so when you have
these people who are classical liberals
who disagree with everything the DNC
stands for but they get in line
I just can't relate to it because I
wouldn't be able to do it right I agree
with you
I don't have great respect for liberals
but there they're not my ideological
enemy they're there supporting my
ideological enemy yes that's that's the
difference they don't understand that
I'm their friend right you and I are
protecting liberal values infinitely
more than the left is that's true and I
think you're a good example too of a lot
of these people they sort of it's this
false virtue of finding common ground
and I would say on a second you don't
necessarily need to find common ground
you can be civil and disagree with
someone you don't have to find common
ground you can disagree in a civil way
in not finding coming when you do that
very effectively yeah I almost every day
I make the announcement that the
differences between the left and right
are unbridgeable right okay there is no
middle ground well I I can you name the
subject what's the middle ground this is
a subject people aren't talking about
much today so I'll use it because it
doesn't it's not a hot-button issue
what's the middle ground between
pro-capital punishment I will execute
people slowly it's such a stupid comment
a middle ground what's the middle ground
yeah I'll flip the switch to neutral
I'll let you handle the rise I'm just
you know turn a black guy liberals don't
want a middle ground either because
they're the first to eviscerate any
black guy who steps on a line of their
thinking any any part of you the people
running through the primaries and it's
like all were it's right in step with
each other no Lee that's a great point
can you think of other issues God good
let's go with that that's right the case
of body voice is that God can you show
him yourself there you go no it's not
good look he looks like he has anemia
he's very pale mr. Prager that's why he
hides himself from you he's like in the
garden oh my god is not pale no no I
don't know I don't that that pale I
picture God with a more defined a
jawline I wonder if there's I'm not well
I talk about this all the time there are
other issues for example amnesty I can
understand the idea of dreamers right
people who are anchor babies
think about this it's it's a horrible
act for parents to come here and just
have a baby so they can stay here and
skirt the law but I also understand of
course I'm empathetic to that that kid
or that young adult who didn't do
anything wrong and now they might be
facing some form of deportation
something along those lines
but then you go okay so maybe here we
could find some kind of common ground
but then you realize the left is against
deporting felons from San Francisco and
sanctuary cities we're just saying their
overcrowding our prisons let's send them
back to be tried in their homeland they
say no no that's racist oh you don't
want to find common ground because we
just gave you that one no the bridge
it's it's really people don't like to
face harsh realities that and the harsh
reality here is that the differences are
unbridgeable if the left wins America
loses that is my belief it is one or the
other it's not a matter of compromise
the left needs to be defeated most
almost no liberal other than Dershowitz
maybe one or two others knows that and
most conservatives don't even want to
recognize that right they really don't
understand it I I talk to Republican
Congressmen often privately dinner is
etc and I say please if you don't make
the case that the left is destroying the
West and America you we have no future
we Republicans right they never ever
they should teach if you're running for
dog catcher in Missouri you should be
telling people how the left is
destroying everything the left is
telling teachers not to call kids boys
and girls because they can't impose a
gender identity that is child abuse yeah
what's the middle ground yeah it's funny
you mentioned that dogcatcher my
father-in-law won the title of constable
in Leelanau County in northern Michigan
several decades ago
Chevy goes he just he was the only one
of the ticket he ran four toes in a
local praise that oh I won constantly so
what is that is basically a dog catcher
on top he just never showed up
it was unpaid I was thinking constable
that's not a dog catcher but that was
just a title in the Leelanau County so
yeah
learn something new every that's what I
that's what I heard cop stands for a
constable on Patrol I think constable
was more like I don't know the exact
time I think when people say oh there
goes constable so-and-so they usually
means someone who's kind of a snitch a
narc so they think of it as someone who
reports that's how they used to use it
in Canada but they're silly people oh
well yes well you elected you not you
take that back Canadians elected Justin
Trudeau Justin Trudeau do you know if I
really admired about if I didn't care
about Western civilization I would thank
the Canadians for electing him that guy
has given me more talk stuff from my
talk show than any other current leader
outside of Trump for other reasons I
mean to correct and then he says it was
a joke I know that is that that was not
that was mind blowing oh I didn't mean
it when I told the woman we in Canada we
say people hood not people kinda Hawley
yeah yeah not mankind he was joking I
know we might have bought it if you
weren't the person who said in a
national address
gay lesbian bisexual transgender
pansexual and too spirited he didn't say
that with a straight face maybe we would
have believed that this was a joke even
I talked about this you could find the
most angry blue haired feminists in the
United States of America and say you
know LGBTQA a IP and if you were to go
to them and say what about the number to
the feminist system will you time when
you say two-spirited the angry blue
haired feminists like don't be a dick
like it's that silly and that Prime
Minister used it with a straight face
national address interior you know you
know his his popularity according to
polls is well under that of Donald Trump
in America but nobody tells you that no
no one in the Canadian media tells you
that that is also fascinating
yeah when people talk about government
on media in Quebec that's basically all
we had we had CBC and radio-canada which
was you know it'd be like having PBS but
only PBS there was no privately funded
news when people say the corporate news
man I go hold on a second I understand
there are problems right understand
News soundbite city and selling self
lubricating pocket catheters and some
noxious but what's the alternative
government media like a thank you oh
that's exactly right otherwise there
would be no talk radio and they were the
only America has that by the way did you
hear the interchange that provoked
Trudeau's comment did you hear what the
woman said about maternal love will
change the world
yes that was even stupider yeah that
woman that everybody loved it everybody
thought it was a beautiful comment that
woman doesn't understand maternal love
is universal you she doesn't think that
mothers in Nazi Germany love their
children maternal love is the answer to
the - to evil the world's problems she
lives in the make-believe well she must
have gone to graduate school yeah I
guess if Hitler's mom and breastfed a
little bit longer I would have done it
yeah nope it's not to mention Nazis you
know and Donna like that they wouldn't
like to hear this statistically actually
it's the father figure that has a bigger
impact on young developing father
standards does more than maternal love
to make a good world right sorry
that's a good play and you talk about
that and a difference in male/female our
um why so I know this we've talked about
the statistics on this quite a bit on
the show why do you think that is so now
we're gonna throw my philosophy why do
you think it's such a stark contrast
that if a dad isn't in a household it
affects everything from graduation rate
likelihood to end up in prison in a way
that is not really comparable to if a
mom isn't necessarily around right my
theory on that and it's my theory III
haven't I don't have David to prove this
but I've lived a long time and talked to
a lot of people my my theory is that
boys are lost without a say
sex model hmm that's that's what it is
boys need men to show them how to be men
right if man isn't there he doesn't have
a clue how to be a man girls become
women almost automatically hmm what boys
do not become men automatically they
stay boys do you think that girls become
women automatically that's interesting
do you think it's maybe more because
they're more communicative so they just
communicate with other women whether
it's a mom or a friend yeah
well partially they have much more
dramatic changes in their body we grow
hair but that's about it yeah but but oh
they there are massive signs in their
body that tell them I am now a woman
that we don't have it just doesn't
happen I don't think that's the whole
story and by the way girls becoming
woman doesn't mean that they become
mature or become good or decent or smart
or wise they need models too sure but
but more dramatically the the male
figure and that's why by the way that is
why and this is so unpolitical IAM
correct that is why god is painted as a
he and not a she in the Bible because
when God is if God is compassionate and
kind and cares about the orphan and the
widow then a male says oh it's masculine
to take care of orphans and widows hmm
if it's a goddess who's doing it then
it's not masculine right count me out
yeah that's a good point and it's sort
of expect women tend Annette I mean a
mother is naturally compassionate with
her children it is right I don't want to
say a forced behavior is right but
nurturing alone doesn't make a good
world no you need standards you and
that's that males are four standards
right women are for nurturing we need
both sexes well I think God is also is
also nurturing and so when you look at
that nurturing you see if it was just
the nature it wouldn't really be a
decision so it's virtuous because God
chooses to as well be nurturing along
with setting standards right but it
being being masculine and nurturing
means nurturing is kosher for men
exactly yeah and that's important
because it's not natural to a lot of men
it's not something come back right yes
natural for me to punch the guy when my
well it's I remember when my kids but I
I've had two boys that boys would come
to the door and they would immediately
tackle each other right the the
immediate was it's not a nurturing
response and now can I beat you up yes
exactly it's like two wolf pups
oh no they're happening again we're
gonna have to replace the drywall well
you know it's it's interesting that you
bring that up because I wanted to get to
your book Exodus that you I know you're
working on it's going to be a multi-part
series but this is something that I talk
about a lot with a cioth atheists in the
show we have a theist sort of liberals
in the show and this argument is often
used well if I need a God to tell me not
to kill or not to steal then I'm just a
horrible person I suppose on a second
first off there are some societies where
that's okay but here's the deal you do
need a you may need a guy to tell you to
be loyal you may need a God to tell you
to be nurturing you know we don't
necessarily need a God to tell us what
we know are the worst parts of us in
humanity but you do need a god to
actually bridle some of these instincts
because it's not consistent across
societies let me tell you ah on April
2nd the biggest work of my life is
coming out I thank you for mentioning
it's called the rational Bible yes 500
pages and it's very easily readable
because it's many many many many many
many essays and chapters and thoughts on
life based on the book of Exodus the
second book of the Bible and it's meant
for atheists and believers because it
doesn't ask for any leap of faith but I
open up my introduction with exactly
your point and this is my story when I
was in my early 20s I had problems with
my parents which is not exactly novel
and nevertheless though I moved from
their house when I was 21 there isn't a
week there wasn't a week in my life that
I did not call my parents
wherever I was the reason I did so was
not out of love I did it because I
believed
God commanded me to honor my father and
my mother in the ten commandments that
is the only reason I called them every
week when I had problems with them
so the people who say you don't need God
or a Bible to tell you not to murder
maybe that's true although it wasn't
true 3,000 years ago right maybe it's
truth today but what about that one do
you need a God to tell you to honor your
parents even if you're having problems
with them yes you do exactly it's a very
important point I was speaking with
someone recently who who said I remember
he said man I didn't go to India I
didn't visit India because I was afraid
I would never come back so what do you
mean is I just I'm infatuated with I
said had you have you ever so you
haven't been there you notice there
aren't many wealthy people who go to
India and never returned they don't set
up shop there and I talked about how
there are more flights coming out of
Indians yes more flights coming out of
India how uncharitable actually if you
look at a lot of people from Eastern
religions are and he was talking about
how all religions were started by worse
well you look at about a hundred million
people killed under a distinctly atheist
set of ideals you know communist regimes
my point there was I said we don't need
a religion we don't need a god to tell
us to kill or to be bad to each other
but we do need someone to tell us to be
charitable we do need someone to tell us
to be merciful which by the way was not
even a virtue for a very long time it
was considered a weakness so for the
left it loved use the word nuance these
nuances matter people are naturally bad
we don't even got to tell us anything
that's the great that's the great
left-right divide it's the great secular
religious divide yeah that issue that
was the first thing I realized doing
radio I one night on my earliest years
of doing radio I was on an at night in
the beginning I had a caller and we were
debating about what's the cause it
what's the cause of violent crime in
America and he was saying racism and
poverty and I said no no human nature
and then anyway we were we were arguing
and arguing and then I realized sir wait
can I just ask you a question and he
said of course I said do you think
people are basically good he said yes I
said so sir we just wasted ten minutes
[Laughter]
and that was the truth we wasted 10
minutes yeah that's because he believed
people are basically good
he couldn't blame people for rape and
and murder and burglary
instead he blamed outside forces racism
and poverty right
I don't bling racism poverty for crime
in America I blame people who commit the
crimes right because I know that human
nature is the issue and I know it the
same reason you know it because we're we
are judeo-christian based yeah we are
these this is the byproduct of human
nature speaking of voice of God yeah
every other either you see the yeah the
article by ford.com that went viral this
weekend titled the first case in the
Bible was the first case of hashtag me
too
basically saying oh yeah I'm reading
that to my audience tomorrow I mean it
is clearly the dumbest piece of writing
and I'm not young I've read a lot of
dumb things it's so preposterous that
that Eve was harassed by God and and I
mean it's so it's so beyond belief
I can't even repeat it what's the
premise I you know everybody you've got
to read it I can read the press in a
left-wing Jewish newspaper called the
foreword a female rapper I okay hear
this good the first story in the Bible
was the first case of me - it's written
by this 47 year old woman who says she's
a rabbi which is very possible I'm sorry
to say it's like look at the Pope if the
Pope is Pope that she could be a rabbi
okay and you know so here here is a
young beautiful intelligent naked woman
living in a state of grace she's hungry
so she does the most natural thing in
the world and eats a piece of fruit now
well first of all she wasn't hungry
idiotic point that she was angry she had
every tree in the garden to eat from
right for me I haven't even I haven't
read this yet but my first reaction is
they tell it she's was her ass she was
it was his garden she was at his
property listen you can do anything you
want on my property
whatever you want just don't just don't
it's like listen just don't turn on the
hot tub when I have people who are at my
house
because it doesn't work the pool just
don't do that one thing and they do it
and I go why would you do that so now
you're gonna harass me but it basically
proves the point that liberals think
people are basically dating eve was
basically good maybe she was before the
fall but this where the screw things up
she's and then she goes on safe we're
following her instincts trusting herself
and nourishing her body she's punished
her punishment she will never again feel
safe in her nakedness she will never
again love her body she will never again
know her body is a place of sacred
sovereignty and basically to go Ansan
just describe God as a a is a an
aggressive violators when I read this
stuff I always have the same reaction I
don't know this woman from from Eve but
I am certain I would bet my house she
went to graduate school yeah you have to
go to graduate school to be that stupid
yes well in the funny I mean it no I'm
not being cute you're right
or facetious you learn to be stupid
right well what's so funny is now they
often use the term reductive as an
insult hold on a second what are we
really talking about reduce boiling it
down to its simplest term here right
sometimes it's very useful sometimes
reductive reasoning can be the only tool
that is required when you're at an
impasse so right here I can tell you if
I'm being reductive I can tell you
exactly what the problem is with that
rabbi she sees Eve as God Eve's body is
not it's just it's just exactly what we
talked about after the fall its idolatry
who is God to tell her what she can and
can't do with her body He is God he
created the body and said these are the
rules you broke it even if you just if
you just see this as allegorical it
should be pretty straightforward
yep that's right no they don't the idea
or look to the left a big factor on the
left is the hatred of moral authority
above themselves right it's not just God
it could be the police
they hate the police they hate they hate
parental authority you if you're six
years old now you're a boy and you say
you're a girl you can say you're a girl
the the school will
call you by a girl's name if you're six
I'm talking about not sixteen no exactly
and you don't have to and the school
does not have to tell the parents yeah
where's the common ground their ground
you know it's like huh okay hon a second
how about the common ground don't pump
kids full of puberty blockers hate
speech we're not gonna find a middle
around here
well we did that undercover enob abuse
that really is child abuse puberty
blockers and the child is child abuse it
absolutely it would just it would be
just like pumping your child full of I
don't know some other mind-altering drug
these same people are really against the
overprescribing of ADHD drugs and
children which I also fully understand I
have fully understand it's over
diagnosed kids are over medicated
they're against that when it comes to
stopping their balls from beginning to
function however all of a sudden were a
little bit fuzzy on the rulebook and I
think that's why people are leaving the
left we were in Vermont I don't if you
were saw that video we were under
covered and it was what the healthcare
transgender Town Hall and they were just
saying you know it's just don't believe
the propaganda the hate speech out there
if the child then decides they don't
they want to go the other way by meaning
the other way meaning they just want to
be their actual biological sex you
stopped the puberty blockers and there's
no evidence of ill effects so the
propaganda from Johns Hopkins the
propaganda from liberal surgeons out
there it there is nothing but evidence
that puberty blockers are harmful in
developmental stage they don't care how
could it not be I mean it's absurd no no
I mean just common sense tells that you
mentioned Johns Hopkins you follow your
stuff Johns Hopkins pioneered
transsexual surgery and the guy who
pioneered it no longer does it right no
they say that's an important point
because when I've talked about it they
said well they're they're notable
anti-trans if you look at Johns Hopkins
and you and you look at what they say I
go home saying not really there was
pioneering going on they were early on
it there were early adopters and a lot
of these early adopters have abandoned
it yeah that's correct well you know so
I that comes that's interesting what
this war there are some issues where I
cannot fathom the left small
there what would you say it is in a
situation like that where we're talking
my pubic alright so here here's his my
theory on this okay the the
judeo-christian world rooted in the
Bible the the Bible which I know it has
the left has effectively trivialized and
even demonized but it is the most
important book in history whether you
love it hate it or don't know anything
about it that's just the fact that's not
an opinion
historically it's not even close right
it has it is rooted in a concept called
distinctiveness there are five
distinctions that are at the core of the
biblical worldview the difference
between man and god the difference
between man and animal the difference
between a man and woman the difference
between good and evil the difference
between holy and profane those are the
five and the left has sought and
successfully demolished all of five of
those distinctions there is no
difference between man and animal
there's no difference between man and
God we are all as you said it we are all
gods now there is no difference between
man and woman and that is that is what
they are doing because distinctions mean
there's order order means there's an
order er yeah that's important to that's
the same reason why people don't like
the term intelligent design because it
means that there's a designer that's
right designer an architect yeah you
know you were early on this I know we've
talked about this but I think it's more
important probably now than ever to
revisit when there was was I think was
it carrie prejean it was after the Miss
USA or Miss America pageant you were
debating Perez Hilton and anyway you
talked about back then how the reason
same-sex marriage is an issue that at
least is worthy of discussion it's not
simply hate speech is because and you
differentiate it you said I don't
believe it's comparable to a an
interracial relationship because I
believe a black mother can provide
everything that a white mother can to a
child a same thing for a black father or
white father Asian father he said I do
not believe that
two fathers can provide everything to a
child that two mothers can you said the
danger here is decline without
fundamental interchangeable
fundamentally interchangeable right and
that's right I've been saying that for
25 years I i i knew that the biggest
reason i oppose same-sex marriage was
because of their argument that gender
doesn't matter right that's the core of
the argument love matters not gender the
moment you say gender doesn't matter
it's over that means there is no male
and there is no female and my prediction
has taken place
it just went faster than I could have
ever imagined where you can't call kids
who are five years old boys and girls
the New York subway no longer has
announcements that begin ladies and
gentlemen right the London blue dropped
ladies and gentlemen right we are all
undifferentiated creatures just like
there's no differentiation among nations
this the topic I talked to you about
earlier
they hate distinctions there's no
American and German and French we are
just all mankind
you know Superman gave up his American
citizenship you know that right yeah I
know else yeah very very silly
Captain America also became a commie for
a portion in those comic books it is it
is incredible you know I just might that
was my next question I think you
answered it I was going to ask if when
you said I just I don't believe that men
and women are fundamentally
interchangeable that was always your
reasoning and your opposition to
same-sex marriage it's gonna ask if you
saw it coming down the pike that the
transgenderism was going to become as
catastrophic I wrote it I mean I'm not
bragging but I you you asked me yes 25
years ago I wrote so no you don't want
doesn't have to take my word for it it's
in writing sure I wrote I wrote about
those five distinctions and I said the
left is obliterating the male-female
distinction yeah and people read it and
I remember nobody took it seriously and
I don't blame them but I I saw it it was
as obvious to me as the sun shining
that's the way it is and that's exactly
what's happening and you know what said
aside forget God or all of that stuff
it's just plain sad
it is the one of the great joys of life
to be distinct from a female as a male
right for a woman to celebrate the the
feminine and not the masculine in
herself we all have all sides I'm we're
all aware of that but it doesn't matter
but but it's to to deprive a generation
of that joy the tension between the
sexes is to deprive them of one of the
most meaningful things I read today I
just ended my show I have my notes in
front of me because I'm still in my
radio studio uh yeah so there was an
article in The Daily Mail about how kids
help how British youth think that big
business and right-wing pundits are more
dangerous to the world than Communists
it's mind blown yeah the people who
murdered 100 million non-combatants in
the 20th century yeah okay but touchy
roll is more dangerous anyway so so
listen to this so they quote a law
student in Britain she's at a very
prestigious school the School of
Oriental and African Studies in London
so she said listen to this this this is
I may even write my column on it she
said let's yeah for young people today
we live in a time in which we basically
have no future why would a young person
privileged enough to be at a prestigious
graduate school in London say I have no
future the left has deprived them of so
much of the joys of life including
meaning because secularism doesn't
provide meaning right I mean it provides
a great great government on for secular
government but it provides no meaning if
there is no God and there is no religion
and there is no Bible there is no
transcendent and there is no design and
there is no purpose then why there is no
meaning and and and so they yes she's
right they have date that's what she
believes they have no future the left is
deprived them of a future it's deprived
them of a present you know they don't
even have a present how do you eight
because I know this booklet you're
saying the rationale Bible is how do a
theists respond to that because usually
able to say well I find meaning in the
simple pleasures of life and you know my
family and in you know these issues that
matter to me it's subjective to everyone
that's where they find meaning yes
that's right and I'm glad they do
otherwise they kill themselves and I
don't mean that sarcastically however no
serious philosopher has denied that if
there is no God there is no ultimate
meaning you can find meaning you can
construct meaning to keep yourself sane
but that's all they're doing they're
constructing temporary meaning for this
tiny blip that we are in the universe
for this tiny blip of time that we're
here but the truth is we don't have any
more ultimate meaning than a pebble
right it's just we need to delude
ourselves into meaning because we'll go
crazy if we don't have it but there
really isn't any and that lends itself
an accident right and that lends itself
so well to pseudo-intellectual ISM in
this existentialism like Jim Carrey now
saying my name isn't Jim Nutt this is
all a construction man this is an
illusion you're in basically a computer
program because they feel so it sounds
intelligent but it's them trying to give
themselves meaning and of course that
leaves you open and vulnerable to
charlatans to intellectual charlatans
and I think that's what we've seen full
circle was another thing I covered in
the last month that excuse me that in
there is more belief in voodoo and
Wiccans and astrology among young people
today than ever in American history
that's a good point that's that's okay
the Bible that's that's fairytales right
yeah exactly this the bite what you took
about the Bible you tell us imagine Airy
spaghetti monster I'm gonna go I'll
blame all of my problems on gluten I
don't know what it is but I'm pretty
sure that's our downfall
it is absolutely insane whether it's a
whether it's what you're talking about
in college intellectually whether its
dietary whether it's fitness weight
whatever it comes down to there is more
bullcrap out there today that people buy
and smart people that's what you don't
have to be dumb to be
to be vulnerable to this and you're
seeing smart people now much more
vulnerable
oh no that's why I said this woman would
never have written such nonsense if she
hadn't gone to graduate school
yeah that was that I meant that
literally I do believe I now by the way
I tell parents and I swear before God
that I mean this seriously unless your
child needs to study mathematics or
physics chemistry etc they would do
better to go to Prager University for
free than to go to Princeton yep that's
actually it's very true and I said that
one time to a a young boy whose parents
wanted him to meet me and said you know
can you can give him some advice that's
sure what is it you know what is it you
want to do we said you know I don't
really know it's okay here's one thing
if you don't know what you want to do
take some time figure it out don't go to
college and my parents were horrified
now I wouldn't have said that if he said
I want to be an engineer he said I don't
know telling young people you don't know
figure it out at university is the worst
advice right that's correct
it's like popular DVD in to babysit only
it's a feminist Women's Studies
underwater basket-weaving professor that
one's gonna she's gonna turn out to be a
gym okay
it is at Dennis Prager on Twitter we
have to get going there's always passes
by so quickly the rationale Bible Exodus
one can people look for that now they
could get it now at Amazon the rationale
Bible I promise it will change your life
if you're eaten I promise yes and by the
way for people who are listening we have
a lot of listeners who are kind of left
we don't really have far left us but
classical liberals atheists it is I've
listened it to mr. Prager for a long
time it is worthwhile you'll get
something out of it regardless of where
you line up if you're a tantric yogi
living in the Middle East you'll get
something out of it and mr. Prager we
please come back and keep us updated
have someone come in and keep us updated
on the lawsuit with YouTube Thanks I
will anyways it's a it's a joy even just
for me to come on your show oh well it's
a joy to have you on our show we must go
though and then we will uh well we're
not gonna be back because I'm gon work
on from I
[Music]